はいみなさんこんにちは
先ほどご紹介がありました a
プロダクトデザイン学科というところに所属していますあの学科自体はものづくりをし
ているが彼なんですけどその中で中で私だけ
コミュニケーションデザインというのを実証自称ではないですけども言っておりまして
8を守りコミュニティですねコミュニティパワーを
コミュニティの場をどのように盛り上げていくかあるいはどのように記録していくかと
いうことを普段は研究したりある学生と一緒にワークショップやイベントを開いたりし
ています
で今日はですね皆さんと一緒にあの映像について少し考えていきたいなと思っているん
ですけれども
リアルタイムビジョンということでコミュニケーションを
挑発するメディア
というちょっとお話をしていきたいとおもい
今本当に映像時代ですよねもう空は飛んでるはみんな持ってるわってからですね
もう本当に今は分からないですからねどこに飛んでるかわかんない子にはひょっとする
と取ってるかもしれんあの子の中でえっと上空撮影実はやってるぞという方
はれますかあえて上空撮影とよってますか
今日はになっ
今言えないですよねあの2ヶ月ほど前だと
いや僕上空撮影してますと言えるんですけど今ちょっと言えなくて
でもスマホで撮っている方は多いと思うんですけどスマホで例えば飲み会とかあるいは
こう
クラブの集まりとかってちょっと結構ビデオ撮ってるぞという方
おられますか
そういう方には必見ですあの
コミュニケーションというかなあの場をものすごく映像って盛り上げるんですねそれは
なぜか
言葉では言葉での記録できない
その人の表情とかあるいはあこんなこともあったんだ
高く設定ですけど
いろんなことが与えられるそしてもう一つ映像にすごい力があるのは憧れを見やすい
あ
こんなことはこんなに広い世界があるんだ
特にそうですねあの空飛ぶ機会は今まで見たことないん
うん違って言って僕の家すごい
屋根から見れるあれって結局憧れなんですよねっ
そんな憧れ生んだ映像
ちょっとこのエドヴィてくる今から約60年前
これ何の映像でしょうか何の写真でしょう
これは
街頭テレビ
この中で該当てるに
見られた実際に体験された方
申し上げたいああ
あの本当に神経に南てますよね
何見てるんだろうこの軍艦の中では
チョップ1
あるいは a
野球とかあるいは憧れの人が歌ってるみんな憧れですわぁすごいな
僕もいつか私もいつかこんな世界にあの四角い箱の中に何か僕の未来あるかもしれない
そんな憧れを持っていた60年前
それから時代は魚をれました今度今頑張ってい今や本当に一億総を
a の時代そんな時代にちょっともう一枚写真を見て見てもらう
さあこれみんな見てますね何を見てるんでしょう
モニターが1234いっ
5台並んでます
これ何を見ていると思いますか
何ですみんな真剣なん子供が時に真剣なんですけどあの前 new のお子様を子ども
たちですね後ろにいるのここじゃ
みんな真剣です送っ
約3分間の無意味なんですけどもこんな映像を見ている
と思われた方もいい
思われた方もいるかも知れますこれは実は子どもたちが出ている
映像をまあそのものなん
子どもたちあの先ほどの会場ではワークショップ
まあアートのイベントしで
作っています
神経っていうかもっ
それをスタッフと言われますと言うとね
嫌がる人も言えばあるいはすごくこ on キャ
巨泉な映像
最後にんじゃあみなさんおつかれさまでした多様なは出ないって
さぁ今日家にちゃったことを3分で振り返ってみましょうという曲名済み
知ったらこの顔ですうーんなんだこれ
あっ飛んじゃっ
これ見ちゃう
もうみんな真剣ですよ一人だけちょっと違うところですね
これはねこの子はね実はすごくて
このあのとっている映画観てる映像もとってるねスタッフがその1
もうちょっとっ
実話エピソードがやってこの子は実はこの後ですねええ
8我々の活動にずっと参加してくれてて
今のカメラマンちびっこガメラまでして
犬とさせしてなきゃ鏡やんですよでもこの真剣な少女
そしたらねを
すごいカウントしてるんですねまああーおれ
10回でた
お前さぁ初回しか出てねえじゃん向かって言ってお互いをお互いおこう
なんだろ牽制しあったりあるいははすごいこんなの作ってろ23いるっていうのを全部
口に出してくれ
つまり一人一人も憧れを覆い求めず近くにいる憧れ
音そっちか昔60年前の
おりたまテレビ映っていた見えないものへの憧れじゃなくて本当に側にその中の
コミュニティの中でお互いにお互いが何をしているのかということを瞬時に確認車
ああああああ
でこの映像本当に普通のおそらく皆さんも映像を作ってずっと見てみてやっていると
思います
でこの映像制作には実はポイントがにを何か起こして言ってるんですけども
大切なのはその場で撮ってその場で見る
つまりカメラマンもエディタさんもうま温泉砂もなんですけども
全員この会場内に入って
みんながやっているところを撮って撮ったものをすーぐ
まあ演出というか塊なんでそこに入ってすぐ編集して
でそしてその場でいるようにん
こういうビデオの取り方をあの撮ってだしとかって言って結婚式ないからね避けられ
てるんですけども
8その結構してちょっとあのとって出すとちょっと違う意味でリアルタイムで4 a と
いうふうに読んで今
これは約3分間の日その場の雰囲気は参加者の様相もリアルタイムで記録編集していく
ことなんですけども
とってまとめてみんなで20
この時のほっぽる失点
これがすごくられていくなる
所得
を説明しましょう
はいとるさんして
これはのぜひ皆さんも試してみてくださいこの3種点をうまくをエディットに入れると
今まで普通のことをやってるのになんでこんなに凄いの
この飲み会なんかとってのグローバルみたいな感じだったよ
はい目指してグループして記述していくようなんですけども一つ目は目指して上空です
速水の上空ですねなんで上空が流行るのかっていうのはこういうことです
人間は寝目指してに弱い
自分を天使の4点ああ神様行ってくれてるっていう視点で見る
見られるとあっ私ってこんな動きしてるんだとか
俺
俺動いて0じゃんっていうかずっと鼻触っているなみたいなことが意外と分かっちゃう
で今までこれって何か警備であのなんだろ監視っていうのはイメージを使ったんです
けども
それを逆転の髪とこれを取ったものをそのまますぐ編集にかけちゃう
で1時間くらいもノーこの1分ぐらいにキュッと縮めちゃうんですね
ちょっ動いているその映像を見るだけでそう
とか皆こんなふうに動くわかるんですね
もう一つはグループしてこれは8ある程度何人かで作業している時には必ず取り
ましょう
例えばボニーなら5人がちゃんと映っている映像を撮ったり1人だけ
ここを半分欠けているとかなってるとは思いを託したのかなと思うんだけど
みんなが打っているかそうか今的グループで楽しかったかな
その時僕って渡してこんな表情であそうか
取り組んでかなと思いそして最後は品説視点
もっと寄っちゃう
普段我々が何気なく全然見ていないこと
例えば本当に書いているペン先
滴る阿部
あれはこう
最近のスマホないかでこうスローモーションでおりますスローモーションは右側を近接
している通り
ん
このさん視点でまず取りますそして
次はまとめるここも大切みんなのいるところでみんなの見えるところでまとめるどう
やってまとめているんだろ後ろから見てもらう
あこんな風にまとめているのかっていうことをまず見てもらってとっている人と
エディッタ
いわゆる編集している人もその場の雰囲気で自分自身がどう
本文ロンドン盛り上がるよそしていじったらどんどん時に身も変えていくということ
ですね
それが大切カメラマンもエディターも参加者はみんなでつくるフィード
の考え方少し持つだけで全然会場も変わります
カメラマンの存在を構え変わりますみんながうつろでもみんなでつくろう
そういうビデオ変わっていきます
みんなでね
最後ここが一番解説どんな状況でもみんなでみましょう
参加者もあるいは準備している人もねそれからカメラもみんなでみましょう
はいとみんなで見るこんな小さな用画面
いやもう画面の大きさなんて関係ない見えてなくても見えて見栄と見栄たくなきゃいけ
ない
とにかくみんなで見る
どんな状況下でも見る飲み会の場所で見たら怒られちゃうでしょうっていう場所でも
見るね
必ず今まだ食ししてるんだからでも見る
これが大切これをしていると本当に
坊
こうだったんだと
好きとそして周りのコミュニティあるいはコミュニケーションをもう一度
あそうかこうなったかということを確認する場となります
は br 耽美出るというのはリアルタイムに取る作る
見るそして自分が何をしたかを振り返るそして他者との関係に気づいてよし新たなこと
をするぞ
you
この4つですねこれを私は
リア右端ビジョンの4 r 飲んでますまずやるた犬
やるタイプのは同時にとにかくやっていうそして
reflection
小冊子するアフリカティカあそうか気づいて最後にリアクション
よし今度は反応する here そのコミュニケーションああああ
が超
を外され
だからビデオっていうのは
今までもませ
広げていくための予報ですでも言葉にならない情報仕草やいろんなことを
挑発するそのバカティブなメディアじゃないから私はそう思うからこのリアルタイムと
いう頑張りあるたび場有
視点で皆さんも日常のなにか
community あるいはコミュニケーション何がやっていることを3分間です
止めてみてください
最後におっしゃっていて発注か10年15年くらい
この大切な故郷東日本大震災の襲った目いいから2年
ちょうど5電話4妻あの一希望はしない色あれば民だをこぼした私たちも少しを頃に
なりました
ウォッチャーしこっちマーレマヤー4コメント
でもそれは
タネを喋らないずっとスタッフと2012んなんとやらという宇宙船に乗っ
でも食費+から次回にこの人たちにこの子たちが将来に入れるあるいは神崎は将来自分
が何をやといった花王
言葉で買えるようになるための映像を作って走っはちゃ
それから5年間っていうのが降り続けていいでしょ
ただし小学校四年生の二が今中学校にほど改善2
4年間発サマー2014年前の自分を三
毎週毎月行っている発動を毎月そのまで見てちょっとずつ自分と
そして自分が憧れている近くの存在ちょっとつ上のお兄さんやお姉さん存在を知って
去年立ってい
実は私この映像を使って
youtube で自分が何をしてきたかを発信したいです
米をかかっ
映像というものは言葉で表せない自分の体験を作ることがで
あるいは残すことができますでもそれが実際に発信できるかどうかというのは人によっ
て長さが違いな
ですから
私はこれからも撮り続けて事実でこの場を共有するつとしてばを超はず
その中でそれぞれが発信できるまでいく映像というものを残して事態と
食堂今日はありがとうございましたいい